die klimaforscher sagen uns dass seit
jahrzehnten sie sagen das länger als ich
auf der welt bin sagen die euch das ist
übertrieben ist die angst das ist also
ein problem das alle
anderen probleme die es je gab glaube
ich überschattet ich bin rebecca ich bin
23 und ich studiere moment ich bin
berthold ostrop und den 84 jahre alt ich
heiße renate an hatte veronika sogar und
in 81 jahre
für mich ist es relativ klar dass das
wichtigste der klimaschutz ist direkt
gefolgt von sozialer gerechtigkeit
das war bis vor einigen jahren war uns
ja noch gar nicht so bei uns älteren
schon noch gar nicht so genannt weil er
hat sicherlich einen wechsel von zu neun
inder wechsel in den letzten jahr machte
ich war und da ist bei mir an die erste
stelle dieses thema gerückt deshalb kann
ich auch die jungen leute verstehen
und 84 jahren noch dass die auch angst
haben all ihre zukunft
[Musik]
die soziale ungerechtigkeit wird nur
noch weiter verschärft wenn die
klimakrise weiter voranschreitet ebenso
ist wird klima immer weiter auch eine
flucht ursache wein ich kann mich
erinnern dass bei uns auf dem bauernhof
und eben die stamm als ich sieben jahre
war da war der endlich zu ende
ein leiterwagen kam mit leuten die aus
schlesien haben eine familie mit sieben
kindern und der mutter und die sind dann
bei uns abgestiegen ein bisschen groß
[Musik]
es werden natürlich für das klima selbst
wäre es gut aber ob das geht das ist
meine meine sorge ich weiß nicht ich
denke mal wir müssen halt einfach
irgendwo mal anfangen oder an vier
stellen so schon etwas weiter und glaube
dass es kaum geht oder gar nicht geht
überhaupt das klima zu retten und die
menschen in wohlstand leben das geht
nicht mal
dass deutschland sich nicht so spaltet
wie das in anderen ländern also in
amerika und so passiert dass es so ein
gegeneinander ist das finde ich ganz
fürchterlich das tier vertrieben ist die
angst
und unsere angebote eine höhere angst
jetzt es fehlt mir auch ein stück also
einmal zuversicht in die in diesem jahr
durch ein zeichen können wir jetzt mal
der wahl setzen
der ort und der tag an dem man ein
zeichen setzen kann und ich setze
anzeigen ein ganz kleines ich werde auch
ein zeichen setzen
[Musik]